started
this is i think session seven of our
classic metal class that we we hold
monthly
and sometimes we talk specifically about
philosophical issues like last time
we were focusing um on the ethical issue
raised by
whether bands can do more than one
farewell tour the answer is pretty much
no
you ought to be ethical but a lot of
times we focus on on music history and
so you know we've done shows on like the
black sabbath the purple nexus
uh early metal uh we two sessions ago we
did a thing on
british metal in the late 70s and so the
natural jumping off point for that
is this massively influential movement
that we call the new wave of british
heavy metal
and it you know we're going to do a lot
of music history stuff
and scott's going to talk a lot about
you know how sonic
profiles are changing and the technology
and and all that we also have a few
things to hash out back and forth that
we've been discussing like
how how influential was punk what to
make of def leppard as new wave of
british heavy metal
so we're going to bring those things in
but i do want to say that i think that
there is a philosophical issue involved
right off the bat
which is how we how we define things how
we
characterize things because you know
when it was happening there was there
was something that could be identified
as a new wave of british heavy metal
right
um but a lot of the people involved in
it
subsequently have said well i'm not
really sure that there was
an integral sort of essential
one-size-fits-all definition for this
maybe it was more of a loose movement
and at the same time we can contrast it
with some of the genres that came out we
can say
for example that the prevalence of glam
metal
in the mid-1980s did something to dampen
the
new wave of the british heavy metal
scene except for those that were glam
like rathchild
so i think there's there are some
philosophical issues there and they have
to do with some of the things we've
talked about before how do you
how do you define where do you draw the
borders how do you characterize things
effectively
and it's really tough to do with musical
movements we're finding out
scott and i as we we hash these things
out and and you know i think all of you
are
kind of involved in that as well in
figuring
those those things out so um
but before we get started let me throw
the ball over to scott and and
ask him do you think that they're do you
think there really really is like a core
to new wave of british heavy metal or is
it really more of a
like a sociological thing that we you
know we can say music history
it kind of fits in but there's no actual
essence to it
um well i think the ear we're talking
about which
i think we agree is like 80 to 83 right
so a few things that i've addressed
before but um
and probably last one uh the last
session uh we have to remember
at 1983 um rock and roll was only about
16 years old and let me clarify that
um of course you know we argue when did
rock and roll start
you know i get it with the blues and you
know
uh elvis and everything but everybody
that's some
you know the metal guitarist will say ed
sullivan
february 9 1964 the beatles
and that's the first time everybody said
we want to form bands joe
even joe walsh steve lucas or every ask
any guitarist and they'll say
that's where rock and roll started for
us
so we have to remember that um if we
follow the history just a little bit i
won't go too much into it but
64. and then by the late 60s we've got
jimi hendrix
um doing his thing we've got deep purple
starting out we have led zeppelin so all
already
five years into the birth of
rock bands um starts doing that so 1980s
not so far out so
i think um i think we can
kind of you know say what the new
movements
are so um you know deep purple lasted
through the
the era and we're going to talk about
the bands that we're going to consider
to be the new wave of metal and you'll
talk about that
um but um
so i mean that's kind of the history of
it so it makes sense like 1980s
happening
everything's new and exciting they're
still pushing the boundaries
uh but then you know maybe we'll talk
later but
um something i talked to greg about
before is a lot of this has to do with
um uh technology
evolving um and production trends
so i think that's some of the stuff
we're gonna get to right
yeah absolutely and we're gonna find
ways to make that not sound abstract and
boring no i'll be very specific actually
yeah i'll be very specific um but yeah
right now i'm trying to give like an
overview
did that answer the question or yeah i
mean
it's interesting when when some of the
people who were involved
in it like i was just reading an
interview today with algae ward from
tank which is
really a very important new wave of
british heavy metal band
and they were interviewing not just him
but also
some of the other people who were
involved in the first generation of that
band
uh the brad brothers and they're all
like yeah
this new wave of british heavy metal
thing we weren't really that into that
so you have a band that's that's
considered central to it
after the fact saying we didn't really
like the other new wave of british heavy
metal bands we were more into zz top
and stuff like that
so go ahead i could interject
you know this is a great thing because
um
we had you and i
that uh we were talking about bloister
cult yeah and
um and one of the members of louisville
saying no we're not heavy metal i don't
even like that stuff that much
and uh you know that being kind of like
uh
what did you say you had this great
comparison about oh with albert comes
through in existentialism yeah
he's he's he he frames himself as not
being an existentialist by relation to
the other existentialists
um but um he also
ends up really fitting into the movement
because
it's the same common themes right so in
music terms i guess we could say there's
there's a common musicality to it
there's a common
origin or background that they're coming
out of i mean we
we i've never really thought this up but
you could think of
metal songs as ways of producing
solutions to particular
problems you know or challenges
can you make a song about rainbows and
and make it make some some sense
sure rainbow in the dark
uh can you can you can you come up with
can you come up with something good for
this riff
um and and i guess you could say that
that bands kind of have those
those sorts of things in common with
each other um
so going back to this yeah it may be
that new wave of british heavy metal
is really there is a common set of
sounds
not one single sound and they're they're
being pushed forward
during the the era so that there's
there's some changes taking place like
iron maiden
in number the beast is is really
it's not a different band but it's a
different sound from iron maiden or even
killers
um or even made in japan that that
concert album
in between those two um so it's kind of
a moving target
they are um influencing each other
they're part of a scene
the older bands haven't entirely exited
except for say deep purple
right but even deep purple is still
around in
gillen in in rainbow you know in the
spin-off bands you could say i guess you
could say white snake is also a
spin-off band since coverdale is in deep
purple
let's uh let's look at what mark is
saying here my hot take
the three most influential bands in
heavy metal are the beetles kiss and
venom
maybe add van halen i guess by extension
this implies venom is the most
definitive new wave of british heavy
metal band i see i wouldn't i wouldn't
go along with that i would say that they
are
important in terms of like inspiring
black metal and so they're massively
influential in that respect but
the most influential um heavy metal band
in in the new wave of british heavy
metal in terms of who influenced other
bands iron maiden
hands down you know and and i think you
could say def
leppard sort of
after that although they almost like
worked themselves out of being new wave
of british heavy metal they're viewed as
as more of an american band and they i
mean they'd actually get like bottles
thrown at them when they're in
england for a while because they're
viewed as being two too american
sounding and having sold out right
um kiss yeah you know kiss when you look
at so this is this is we'll come back to
some of the stuff we're going to talk
about but let's talk about influences
when you look at who the people in the
new wave of british heavy metal
list as influences some of it is
contemporary bands
like some of them will say that they
were influenced by
judas priest or motorhead
tank did a lot of you know sort of were
not a motorhead clone
because they were getting accused of it
i don't see a lot of them
citing kiss i think kiss is really
influential on american metal
um i don't know it's that influential on
the new wave of british heavy metal deep
purples
brought up black sabbath budgie
who else um i mean there are some bands
like thin lizzy of course
even though they're not they're more
metal adjacent than anything else
uh and by the time that they're in in
the
sev mid 70s there they've got scott
gorham there who's an american
um there were american bands like
montrose are are
influencing um the the some of the new
wave of british heavy metal bands but
ufo is also a huge influence um steve
harris of iron maiden says that pete way
was one of his biggest influences
so you know venom is is coming in and
they are important for a certain genre
i don't think they're really influential
on the rest of what's going on in the
new wave of british heavy metal
and i don't think that they're
influential on like power metal
or some of the other genres that are
coming out of it
um but we should talk about the
influence thing so like scott was
pointing out
you know it's a really fertile period
and a short time frame you know
less that less than a decade and a half
from the inception of rock and roll
to the this booming in the 1980s
i mean when you think about these these
bands in the 80s in britain's sky who
who else do you think i've left out in
terms of influences there's the prague
stuff right so who would that include
um oh yeah so the prague bands you know
definitely peter gabriel era genesis
we're talking you know lamb lives over
broad street
okay you know the the 70s peter gabriel
um you know and uh certainly
absolutely yes the band yes you know
yeah
album everybody on that record now why
why do you think the prague stuff was
oh because well the 70s that's a great
question actually
the 70s was explosive in not only rock
but
in jazz so um you know
miles davis of course the 50s and 60s
was playing my funny valentine and all
this stuff
and um and then you have the 70s where
he said i'm sick of this i'm going to go
uh it's going to be one chord it's going
to be a half hour composition it's going
to be
all the musicians interacting with each
other then you get to the late 70s where
he's getting like john schofield and
mike stern on guitar
and they wanted to impress miles with
all these fast jazz licks
and he said he would stop and say hey
mike stern
don't play that stuff turn it up and
play like hendrix
because jimi hendrix was actually booked
to play on [ __ ] brew
but jimmy died before that record came
out the miles davis record i'm speaking
of
but we also had you know these people
like robert fripp
um these british guitar players that
were very experimental brian eno
um you know we had all these people that
were experimental
and um like peter gabriel and this was
like
completely new people that were
listening to stravinsky
um people that were listening but they
wanted loud guitars like uh like on the
yes stuff
you know they'd crank the amp and have a
guitar and so it had rock
um qualities to it right and you'd have
the singer kind of you know
um whatever the band was you know the
singer kind of belting it out
and i think you know i'll definitely say
steve harris put that together
incredibly well because i want to go
back to something you said
the paul diano period and we were
talking about this the other day
i said you know it's definitely got a
punk flavor and
you said like you know steve harris said
there's no punk in there and we both
agreed that paul diana
was the factor or the variable that made
them
punk you know yeah
i i mean i don't think you i think steve
harris is right that iron maiden
is not itself punk there there are some
some
musical aspects that are in common like
the
drive-ahead raw energy speeding things
up
right but the thing that's that harris
talks about in interviews is he said
these punk players weren't very good
technically you know they they didn't
they didn't focus on their instruments
and um and you can also say that about
venom i mean
uh henry rollins famously like you know
said when we played with them they
actually couldn't play
they got better over time you know but
and so there i think you could say
there's something of the punk mentality
but i don't think there's like i don't
think there's like influence by punk
where they're they're like we we sh we
should sound like these punk bands we
should
for example the lyrical quality or
lyrical um content
um this is something that like uh donna
weinstein in her book on heavy metal she
focuses on quite a bit there's another
really good book out there called
and i don't remember who it's by this
ain't the summer of love contrasting
punk and heavy metal and you know the
the lyrics could be similar
so think about running free for iron
maiden right it's a classical
rebel against the world he's got a
pickup truck he's out of money he's out
of luck he's got to be in prison
or jail um and it's it's him against the
world and that that is
probably one of the most punkish songs
of iron maiden
uh at the time but it's it's not
actually it's not punk
in the way that we're used to seeing in
the 70s developing
there's a different aesthetic there's a
different
um set of you could call them
non-political commitments
again that's something that that
weinstein is really focused on there's
and and heavy metal was viewed by a lot
of people as escapism
yeah not being politically committed
when it should be like like punk was
um now granted paul diana is essentially
a punk singer
and maybe that's why he didn't he didn't
fit so well
with iron maiden algae ward one of the
other you know
so lg ward played in actual punk bands
the damn the saints
right and then he comes to tank
and he's the he's the driving factor he
hires these two brothers the brobz
brothers to play guitar and play
uh drums and you know when he's asked
about it he said no we weren't punk we
were we're high energy
we were aggressive we were like we were
gonna
do whatever the hell we wanted to but we
weren't like these these punk bands
over there so i i i'm you know then if
we get away from those
examples and we're looking at something
like raven i don't know is raven
even close to punk or is um
or take def leppard right there's
there's nothing that you would look at
with old def leppard and say well that
sounds like a punk band to me
not jeff leopard no yeah and or saxon
right so no saxon was almost
the early saxon stuff um
i feel like you know the stuff they put
out kind of around the same time as
maiden or the year after
i feel like some of the guitar parts
were made in esk
yeah like well you said that you know
the peers were kind of like hearing each
other and incorporating stuff but
you know even queens like a seattle band
but um
i feel like def leppard was the center
um for a lot of the bands you're
speaking of yeah exactly like denim and
leather that album what year was that
was that 83
um that sounds about right it might have
been 82.
uh strong armor law is what 81
i think so and actually so
um mark asked was motorhead's first
album punk and so this is kind of a good
segue into talking something else um
that that that's connected to what's
what what scott is is is bringing up as
well
so the bands that were influencing each
other judas priest
and and motorhead are exerting a big
influence
on on the scene at the time i wouldn't
say that motorhead's first album is punk
i would say
it it's it's with it's it's very gritty
metal
um and motorhead themselves um
don't define themselves as metal or punk
they would say we just play rock and
roll but they play rock and roll turn up
as much as
as you can using lemmy's kind of unique
approach
where the bass is also the rhythm guitar
and um
you know he he um
i mean so larry wallace right he's
coming out of the pink fair he's
arguably a punk band
um i guess you could say early really
really early motorhead has more
punkish aspect to it but i think it's
it's
some people want to say it's like a
crossover band but i don't know i think
it's still more metal
um and punk i mean the thing about
you know lemmy always said we're not
metal we're rock and roll
yeah you know he always considered
himself you know uh
well i don't know if i didn't hear him
say this but i feel like he considered
himself
um the rolling stones uh more drunk and
turned up louder
you know you know in another interview
he
he said he liked the beatles instead of
the stones
because i think we talked about this
before because the stones were coming
essentially from a bourgeois
sort of background and the beatles were
real working people
and liverpool yeah so so it was kind of
kind of interesting uh he he
is a very important class dynamics but
but going back to it
you know so this is something i do want
to say and i realize we've been all over
the map so far
when when people talk retrospectively
about the new wave of british heavy
metal
they often include motorhead and judas
priest in there
and then other people will come along
and say no they can't be
new wave of british heavy metal because
they were already established acts by by
1980
and exerting a significant um let's call
it a significant influence on on the
scene right
and and part of that influence was by
actually offering these newer acts
the possibility of touring with them so
like girl school tours with
motorhead for example or um iron maiden
actually at one point tours with judas
priest
as the opener for a judas priest so
these bands are
they're i like to call them um catalysts
or uh precursor bands you know in the
chemical sense
they are providing uh a basis for
for these newer bands to to come in um
you know so oftentimes people say oh
what was the new wave of british heavy
metal judas priest saxon iron maiden
def leppard motorhead and really only
you know
only iron maiden uh saxon and def
leppard fit into that new wave of
british heavy metal but that doesn't
mean that these other bands aren't
important and aren't playing a really
central role i would say as well that
uh gillen's band gillen was playing a
pretty important role as a precursor
band
at the time as was rainbow you know
although rainbow starts to take a more
aor hard rock kind of
direction and then ufo was doing the
same thing at the time
as well you know so go ahead
i'm sorry i think this is i was going to
bring this up at some point but you did
um you know we can talk about you know
deep purple the late 60s so they're off
but you know um richie blackmore
reinvents himself
he gets jolyn turner in the band yeah
and um
they get back together well actually no
uh he got back with ian gillen for
perfect strangers in 83
yeah no was it eighty-four i think it
was eighty-four
and so yeah okay that's a new deep
purple album but rainbow
um you know there's this thing it's like
um you listen to
um you know heart difficult to cure
yeah uh yeah it's
aor in the sense that it's a little more
melodic
as far as like you know aor adult
oriented rock or melodic rock
but blackmore and the rifts and
everything didn't suffer
so um i wouldn't discount
rainbow unless you just want to discount
that like blackboard's been in the
business for a while but i do think
when those records came out they were
kind of fresh for the times
yeah the rainbow i think there i mean
there is a shift
um this is something that you and i have
talked about a bit
from the organ use right
as the keyboard used to to more 1980s
synth keyboard which is a a bit of a
softer and
more high-end sound i would say with
organs you have
like in rainbow so rainbow was a band
that was like deep purple
like um uriah heap where the
organ and the guitar are occupying a lot
of similar sonic space right
both of them can do riffs
so like when deep purple is playing and
john and richie blackmore's soloing
um the riff is being done by john lord
you know or in uriah heap um it's
whoever's
whoever was on the keyboard at the time
they lost keyboard players from time to
time
um i think moving away from the albums
that dio was on
there were so many other um changes in
the background
that i think that the keyboard sound
like so when you think about like um
street of dreams right that is is a
prime example of 1980s
rainbow and it's it's using a keyboard
and it's not to say that you can't do it
i mean d.o
on holy diver and uh
last in line same sort of keyboard but
it's it's
it's uh being used with i would say a
heavier guitar riff
um and uh i think he had jimmy being on
base right who'd
come over from rainbow at that time and
the base stuff on that
on those early albums is also really
heavy too
so yeah i i mean i agree with you we
shouldn't we shouldn't totally write off
and i wasn't meaning to do that or a ufo
for that matter which was also doing a
similar
shift um you know uh just to add to the
list
i mean they're they're not british
they're german but okay the scorpions
they get rid of john roth michael
shanker
and then we have the new 1981 version of
love at first sting
you know this is here's where some bands
that's 1984 right oh god
because he because love drive is the one
where
um where they switch and there is a
difference in sound
um a complete difference so yeah i think
this is something you said
at the beginning of this whole thing is
that you know something we should
consider is a complete
change in the personnel like diano going
to brazil
yeah otherwise the same band but a
completely different sound by number of
the beast
you know and so one of the things we're
going to talk about later on in this
um is the challenges that some of the
new wave of british heavy metal bands
went through because there was a scene
right and so we can talk about there
being a british scene
we can talk about there being a broader
european scene we can talk about
a new york scene an la scene developing
in this time
and when you have a scene you have all
these different possibilities for people
to go from
from place to place and so if you get
fired from one band you can go to
another one
there were some bands in the new wave of
british heavy metal that
never really attained a stable lineup
and that that's part of what killed them
iron
if iron maiden hadn't finally settled
down because in their early years they
you know people were kind of shuffling
in and out right
and if you don't have a stable lineup
you can't have
really a stable sound you can't
gel together as a band and and progress
and so some of the bands that were
quite you know interesting and had some
real prospects but
never really made it to the next level
would be like
tigers pantene or
angel witch angel which was a very
important band in the early part of
new wave of british heavy metal but they
weren't able to sustain what they were
doing because
people were constantly going in and
going out you know
at one point somebody said it's
basically whoever's the the guitar guys
got playing with them
right and so you can't attain a
the musical equivalent of an ethos by by
doing that i think
right i mean it's different when you
have a solo act like ozzy osbourne can
fire everybody and hire all new people
and it'll still be ozzie's voice and you
know in a way it matters because he
doesn't write his own songs
so you know um who he's got backing him
up well it will matter quite a bit but
sharon actually handle
all of that right hiring and firing
people
but when it comes to a band where you
don't have a
single identifiable um
front person you really need to have
um you know the same set of people right
mark now mark has an interesting point
diamond hen were a great band that went
nowhere
yeah and in that case it wasn't so much
about turnover
um the two biggest challenges were
management
um they they allowed the management to
be family members
never a good idea right and
um they changed their sound by their
third album
they were moving more towards a uh a
less metal
more more um i'm not sure how you
describe it
their their canterbury album um
i guess you could say aor kind of sound
you know
and and so that lost them some some
people
a lot of the problems too are getting
getting and keeping record deals
um record companies would sometimes
uh stiff the bands you know they'd have
them do a tour
in support of a particular band that was
well established and then they would
just cut their they'd
destroy the deal afterwards um so
if you didn't have somebody like in your
corner looking out for you it was pretty
easy to get screwed
and a lot of those things had nothing to
do with musical talent or quality it was
just um
you know bad luck in some respect
well i do want to say um you know this
that's a great point and if i can
interject on the on the on the business
side in
in history actually this is something we
didn't even discuss
um
you know i know we you know everybody
said that the record companies were were
horrible they were demons and
yeah some bands signed bad deals but
here's the thing
yeah take um take so many bands that did
six flop albums
but the company kept investing in them
because they said it's gonna pay off
right so it's the old school you know
cigar chomping
executive back then yeah and um
you know they would say well this band
sold a million
or two million in the first week or
whatever and
let's do that let's do more of that the
problem came in when they got the young
guys with ponytails in there
and said like you know go out and get
these bands and um
it would then it became exactly what you
said and you know this was more kind of
in the 90s where
um i have a friend that had a band um
that was a metal band you know from
the boston area i won't name them but
their first album went
uh gold their second album sold pretty
well
but not good enough and they got dropped
from the label which i won't mention but
um but back then you know if you
did sign an okay deal like let's say you
know some of these bands they could have
been like
shoved a contract while they're half
drunk after a set at a club
signed signed away their soul um bad on
them
but at least back then there's a lot of
bands i mean
i know for a fact like i don't know why
this isn't metal at all but arya's
speedwagon
put out like six or seven flop albums
and then high infidelity came out
and epic made millions and millions of
albums
so that was kind of it's kind of like
cheers if anybody remembers the show
cheers
yeah yeah the first six seven seasons
flopped
but you know they they knew they had
something
so now but then you remember like tv in
the 90s
a show didn't get the ratings they won
on the first one and then you'd see the
pilot and then it would just disappear
so i think you're right that a lot of
them did get
screwed out of deals back then you're
completely right but
by the 90s it was just ridiculous and um
you know now um i think a lot of people
are praying for the record companies
because
nowadays what a metal band has to do is
come up with a kickstarter
or you know right yeah yeah invest their
own money and then they hand it over to
spotify for spotify or band camp
to take the lion's share of it at least
you know if epic records signed a metal
band back in the 80s
they'd say here's 20 grand to record an
album we're going to put you on tour pay
for your hotels
you're going to sell merch and we're
going to take a big percentage to recoup
our investment
well that sure beats you investing it
and then going nowhere
and then just you know so i think that's
important
and and you know there was also the rise
of smaller independent record labels
that could step in and
be a bit more you could say more
speculative in terms of their investing
or risky in terms of their investing but
it would be smaller amounts like we'll
press
you know 4 000 uh copies of your your ep
and and then we'll see how it sells in
the record stores but there was there
was also a distribution
network that is is lacking today
let's go take a few of these uh uh
questions and comments here so mark has
a good point grim
reaper missed the bus there were a lot
of good a lot of great
new wave of heavy metal bands that would
have done better if their albums had
come out two years earlier and that's
something we'll we'll talk about
that point yeah yeah absolutely
you know chrome molly is another example
of a really good
new wave of british heavy metal band but
their stuff came out
from like 1984 onward and there were
certain
let's call them musical forces and
market forces
that began to really restrict not heavy
metal itself
but certain kinds of heavy metal and
then favor other kinds of heavy metals
so like
mtv becoming the massive influencer that
it was
and mtv for a while was actually almost
dominated by heavy metal
they had to like start restricting it
and like you know have just a show for
it right because otherwise people were
constantly requesting it
but they weren't requesting new wave of
british heavy metal bands they weren't
they they would request iron maiden but
they weren't requesting raven they
weren't requesting venom
they weren't requesting these other
bands instead it was american glam bands
for the most part
so that that was a major uh influence
and then you know by the time that we
get into the late 80s
and early 90s that was that that becomes
the the really
tough period for quite a few metal bands
whose arc if it you're right if it had
been a little bit earlier
they probably would have done a bit
better so that's
i think what are you going to say scott
i know you had something on your mind
with that
well i have a few things first of all
chris the bird sounds that's me
we have parakeets that's why myself when
greg's talking so it doesn't
distract so i hope that's not bothering
everyone
um if you don't mind i want to get to
some of these questions that i think
absolutely so chris kansas is a great
example of a maid
uh of a band whose record companies
should buy them
you know you're absolutely right kansas
big time you know um and then you know
of course they come out with the
greatest hits which has
they could have put like a double album
for that and you know
i want to go back kansas was a huge
influence
on well like dream theater
um i don't you know maybe if you ask
some of the british metal bands but
kansas was
a band that was playing prague they were
you know
classical uh composition
parts these long nice compositions where
it wasn't just you know
let's go back to you know the 50s with
elvis elvis was fantastic
all that music was great or early
beetles where it's you know three chords
but
great three chords but now you have
bands like kansas and i forgot to
mention them
so chris that's a great point um
uh alfonso i didn't want to uh miss this
those types of deals seem like light
years away from spotify corporatizing
happening now
i agree with you on the sense of the
dollar here's your wealthy check
and you know that's why i pulled all my
stuff off of there if you want to
you know i have plenty of free videos
for people to see on youtube
but i sell my stuff through my website
and i keep 100
of it and i i sell it for less than
cdbaby would or amazon so
you know that's a different subject this
brings up a kind of interesting
digression
um and maybe you have some i think i've
brought this up before and maybe you
have some better insight on on this
scott um so there's there's quite a few
bands
including budgie who chris brought up
where you can't get
a lot of their stuff on itunes
or well now it's apple music or in
google play or other
things and it seems like like apple
music kind of leads it if it's available
there it's going to be available
in in other places right and you know
like so with budgie their first two
albums are available from like 1971
1972.
nothing else if you want like i was
listening last night to one of the
the ones that i i put into the
discography as a set of recommendations
um and if you want to find it you have
to go to youtube
and and it is available there not in
youtube music by the way but just
because some fan
uploaded it and it hasn't been taken
down yet by anybody
and there's so many of these um new wave
of british heavy metal bands
where a good portion of their catalog is
just not available tank is a prime
example
um you can't you can't find um
a good portion like you can't find honor
and blood which is probably
their best album i would say from 1984.
um you can find a few of their things
but
you can't find the rest and it's also
like if you search tank you get this
rapper from milwaukee
unfortunately is the main thing so i get
how with with some of the really
obscure bands that don't really have a
presence because they broke up and and
like nobody's even quite sure
maybe who owns their music why that
wouldn't be
available but with the bands that do
exist and are still
out there what's going on why why would
why would only like two albums of budgie
be available when
all you know all this other they've got
a massive catalog
why what's the what's the story with
that do you have any idea because
it frustrates the hell out of me so um
first of all when a lot of these bands
when they signed
the record deals they didn't read that
the record company owns it
so for example um
uh well i don't know why joni mitchell
came up but all the stuff she did
for uh you know the wild things run fast
the early 80s
um she did four albums for i don't
remember the company
but they went out of print because the
company wasn't making money and
she had to go oh geffen she had to go to
david geffen's office
and say the tapes are just sitting there
you know give them to me they're like no
give us a million dollars
you know so this is what happens with
metal bands now
you notice do you notice that a lot of
the metal bands
in the last 15 20 years have been
re-recording albums like
great white for example re-recorded the
first album okay
now and the reason they did that is
because they don't own the tapes of the
first album and
they can't put it out or if it's thrown
out so they're not remastering
they're they're actually like entirely
recording the tracks yeah they do they
so great white did the first album lady
red light on
and um they did it as close as they
could to the original which
is impossible but it was close and
here's the thing
because i don't know what i don't forget
their label if the label put it out
they they they said great white gets
zero percent
of the sales so for great white they
still own their publishing
and they still own their songwriting so
if they record the whole album and put
it out and fans buy it they get a
hundred percent of it
so i think um lynch mob just did that
right
so george lynch and lynch mob just did
um wicked sensation recorded that whole
album again
and the reason was because they don't
own
the rights to the recording they own the
rights to the songs
so um you know i almost want to buy it
to hear it but also you know
george is a legend but i think this is
this is what you're asking is pretty
much
why aren't these albums available and
like your first thought is well if the
bands were on it they just put it on
their website but they don't they'd be
sued
because they don't own yeah and you know
it's it's it's a
it's kind of a problem from a let's call
it music education
perspective because if like so the
discography that i
i made you know and i just kind of put
put a
easy one together we could put together
much longer ones people have done that
on websites
if you can't actually get these albums
you can't hear
what's being offered so you know good
example of this would be
some of the you know let's call them
second tier bands like like chrome molly
or jaguar um
you know if you if there's no
availability of their
their music no ready availability um
you're not going to get a new generation
of fans into it and they'll just
disappear
sort of like going into the the old
monastic
library archives and then there could be
a renaissance when people come in and
rediscover this stuff but
that's leaving everything up to chance
in in many respects
what i would do um just my two cents um
and not that i would that i i i'm
pretending to know better than these
bands what to do because every
situation but yeah yeah if let's say if
it was my catalog
i would probably get the band together
let's say it was a band
and i would rehearse for a month
and like you know six days a week and
then um
sell tickets to a house of blue show and
do
two shows that are the same so a seven
to eight
thirty and then a ten to eleven thirty
shows okay
so and then i would put out a live album
because
in the end most of these bands own the
publishing and
the writing credits the music which is
where the money is
so you got a live album yeah and then
that's available and it's got your
old hits that the fans might want to
hear maybe put a few new tunes
but that's how it would draw a new
generation so bands like strange ways
and
you know some of the aor bands they lost
the rights to it
and they they would do shows in the last
five years and
they'd say you know these 20 year old
kids were coming up to us and we were
big in 86
and we said how how did you find us and
they said youtube
and you know and there are a lot of new
wave of british heavy metal bands that
because of the
um let's call it renaissance of metal
in the 2000s um they're back together
and they're
they're producing stuff sometimes it's
you know it's very different than what
what their original stuff was but they
they usually also have to play the fan
favorites
right from their their old catalog so
i just uh alfonso asks a great question
music published so complicated
you know what he's absolutely right what
do you think about i get nauseated to
speaking about the words i mean there
there probably is
kind of a reaction of what is this
nonsense you know
um and so that's that's a good segue
actually so back to the music itself
right
one of the things i we'll talk in a bit
about how like distribution
changed and how bands were able to get
out there but i really wanted to bring
scott on
again to talk about sonic elements and
the technology
when we talk about the new wave of
british heavy metal metal has gotten
faster it's gotten heavier in some
respects
than stuff that was happening in the 70s
how did that happen what was what was
driving that
it's not just like the thrash thing
where people are like let's play as fast
as we possibly can
that's not what's going on there's other
things that are that are happening in
terms of the instruments in terms of the
um amps right and in terms of playing
styles
so i'm gonna turn that entirely over to
you
um so um we look back now and we'll say
like you know richie blackmore what a
tone
or you know um any
you know uh even ted nugent or
um you know anybody from the detroit
sound
you know um mc5 you know and you know
was there something in the water we all
asked and um
we come to find out that you know
they weren't you know gear back in the
70s in
in well in the 70s let's say was pretty
much you had a few things for amps you
had the marshall stacks
or you had the clean fender amps right
those are the two
choices you basically have there was
some other companies but
um and then there was a few you could
have a gibson or a fender
essentially those were like you know
with you know you
either saw someone with a telly a strat
by fender or a gibson les paul and
marshalls and um
and that's what was available like peter
frampton frampton comes live
marshall's and les pauls and we look
back and go
wow those are amazing tones and if you
ask any of these guitarists and i have
they go i'd like to tell you that there
was a magic to it
but we just used what gear was there and
um so i i told uh
greg just to jump ahead for a second to
give you a
a balancing so the and i don't know why
i'm using this band as an example it's
just because i happen to see them live
and be shocked
so lover boy the early 80s great guitar
tones
les paul and a martial and um then
i saw a show with like joan jett and
lover boy and all these bands one of the
summer tours
and the guy was using a marshall
it's called the jcm-900 now let me
explain
that amp was made it's a marshall in the
90s
as time went on these amp companies made
amps
have more distortion so in the past they
would just like you know
the ufo or whatever they cranked the
marshall and you'd get some gain but it
wasn't like
it wasn't like mushy so the 900
was probably the mushiest crappiest
sounding amp for that stuff but the
guitarist was using it
and um you know my thing was like you
had great
great tone what happened i just use
what's around you know whatever the new
thing is it's on stage or it's in the
studio
so this brings to the the thing about
1980.
so uh greg had mentioned you know uh
organ versus keyboard sound so i think
about 8283
there's a keyboard that was polyphonic
and that means you could play more than
one note at a time
and you can get a kind of an organ sound
kind of a piano sound
it was compact so
um producers would get bands in the
studio and go
this is the new thing this is it it's
compact you don't have to lug all this
stuff
and um you know we could take judas
priest turbo that we talk about right
which may have been a little ambitious
on the uh
on the dx7 well yeah that was probably
dx7 and
that's a nice euphemism for it
ambitious yeah that's yeah and
um so i think what happened was we heard
guitars get
uh more and more uh
gamey but let's just say surreal
sounding it's not that ac dc
that one chord you can hear the now when
we get
to the def leppard album hysteria
and uh iron maiden somewhere in time
which was approximately the same time
both i mean pyromania no no
hysteria so seriously oh right right
right
yeah so yeah yeah i'm
assuming everybody knows the band boston
you know don't look back
and you know more than a feeling but
there's a sound
that was made by the guitarist tom
schultz who was an mit graduate so he
built his own
he built the first digital amp back then
and um so what it was is you would
instead of like a tube amp
they would crank up you would have this
digital amp with effects built into it
and you would plug in so
all of hysteria was made with what was
called the rockman
and the rockman was this digital amp
that
the sounds you hear on the boston albums
and so hysteria
hysteria and uh somewhere in time were
now
this is sacrilege right we have these
guys that were cranking marshals with
les pauls and strats
getting these great tones
now running with the technology and if
you look if you have somewhere in time
there's
guitar synth on it right on um stranger
in a strange land
and i think it sounds cool though and
then that chord that happens
that sounds like a synth that's adrian
smith playing this guitar synth
so this stuff didn't exist in the 70s
but not only was it the new stuff and
these you know these players it turns
out used just what was in the studios
you know
like or you know what they're what they
bought
there wasn't as now we have a
million boutique amp companies a million
boutique
pedal companies now it's like out of
control but even the 80s
nobody was doing what the 70s was so in
other words adrian smith went to a a
jackson which is like a super stress so
fender strats were made by leo fender in
the 50s
uh maybe earlier we made the no casters
so
anyways if you notice the pointy guitars
in the 80s
and the the hockey stick headstocks yeah
um
so these were things that were like
these are gonna stay in tune better
these are gonna you know we have these
new pickups we've made
and so now they're starting to play in
the sound is changing
so um so you know it's like you know
everybody's like
we've made groundbreaking things to the
technology of the 70s
so uh and the floyd rose alfonso and
yeah so they had these trim bars that
you could pull up and push down
and hit to make cricket sounds that
didn't exist in the 70s
let me ask you one sort of very uh
pointed question about about sound stuff
so you know a lot of people associate
distortion with metal and when you
listen to 70s metal there's a lot of
overdriving right as you're pointing out
and then if you take a band like judah's
priest as a prime example because there
we've got continuity right you listen to
sin after sin and then compare that to
um british steel there's been a
progression in terms of like how much
is is is going on and i would say that
you know
in there is distortion being used on
some of the songs in
sin after sin like think about
lettuce prey or dissident aggressor
but it's not being used in the same
almost like routine way
by the time that you get to british
steel
let alone screaming for vengeance it's
like well this is just the way we play
our guitars now
it's distorted and a lot of the new wave
of british heavy metal
bands there's going to be some measure
of distortion
it probably won't be there in a lot of
the guitar solos right then
you're switching and you're playing a
more clean sound i think on on a lot of
the
the solos but with the riffs it's
so where is where is this coming from
technologically is it is it pedals
that are that are now coming into play
is that the way that the
system is set up what the pedals weren't
in play yet so
what we're talking about with pedals is
um normally you'd plug your guitar right
into the amp
and there's tubes in it because there's
tubes and tvs and radios
and just by default and leo fender the
adventure of fender guitars and amps oh
yeah
um he always wanted his amps clean but
these everybody found out if they turned
the amp all the way up it would put the
tubes in distress these damn kids
yeah and he was like get off my lawn so
he would
keep making his harder because he wanted
country players to play and clean
so anyways what happened was there was
the jmp
marshall in the late 70s and that was
still you had to
turn the volume all the way up and it
would distort
put the the tubes in distress then there
was this
new wave of metal like you know and it
was you know it was getting
heavier the genre wanted to progress
but the companies came out so
jcm 800 the 800 means 80s
the jcm 900 means 90s the jcm2000
means the 2000s so when the 800 comes
out and now
if you turn it up it's even more
mushy or gainy then by
and don't quote me on this i think 84
they added an extra gain stage in the
800.
so now this was showing up in the
studios and um
you know take something like john sykes
you know from white snake
or from thin lizzy before yeah you know
he was just cranking the old marshalls
and by the time the 800 came along his
tone
changed entirely much more distorted but
um but you know i think he had control
of little sound
so are you gonna say something greg or
well i was wondering so it
it with the earlier things i mean this
this partly goes to
one of the key definitional elements of
heavy metal which which
people are going to say well this is
super trivial it gets played loud
right and and i'm just remembering again
in that algae ward interview
fast eddie clark produced uh one of
their albums it was the second album
and his his advice was basically you
just need to be louder
and so i i what i'm hearing in part is
that being louder wasn't just
like a jump in in quantity
it's also changing quality you get more
distortion
as you're getting louder so it makes it
possible for bands like when they're
recording in the studio
you probably would have had to crank
things up you know in order to get the
the distortion effect that you want
right
and then what what i was going to say
what a lot of these companies did is
they had something called a master
volume so
um if i can explain this yeah there's a
power
there's power tubes and preamp tools the
power tubes are like these big tubes
they look like light bulbs
you turn the amp on they start glowing
it's pretty cool so
what the the the goal in the 70s was you
crank it
and the power tubes go into distress
okay
then they came up with this thing where
we want distortion but not so loud
so they would have the master volume so
you have the volume you turn the volume
all the way up and push the
power tubes into distress and you take
the master volume and dial it down
so now the theory was you'd have
much more distortion at much lower
volumes
okay it didn't sound as good so then
these amp companies had to put in
specific
distortion channels so people could play
them not so loud
but this is part of the sonic aspect so
i would say
the dx7 and then the d50 for keyboards
um we we heard synth sounds and of
course white snake the beginning of here
i go again
um but even like that white snake album
by 87 that's
heavy distortion that's the jcm 800
duped up
and um but you listen to john sykes and
thin lizzie
he's got the same um aggression in his
plane
but um you know this this is like
totally off topic
and we should take emily's question in
just a minute because that'll lead us
into something but
i was thinking so with these these
developments that you're talking about
and eventually
you could say it's a distortion becoming
easier and easier to come by
and available in a more flexible way
right without that there's no grunge
there's no grunge movement because one
of the things that grunge and heavy
metal have in common besides you know
hard driving bass lines
is distorted guitars it's just you know
there aren't so many guitar solos and
things are being done a bit differently
but
um there's heavy heavy distortion on on
most of those
those grunge bands right well and a lot
of it's coming i think through pedals
isn't it
i see his ears as reactionary so okay
um i'm not going to go on a such a
tangent but this i think
so the 70s happened we have guys like
eric clapton
and the allman brothers taking 30-minute
guitar solos
right yeah all these long jams some
might call themself indulgent
and then we had the short era of punk
cbg beasts in new york city
where bands like the ramones said no two
minute songs
no solos and no long endings you know
like the long endings where they just
play one chord and then yeah yeah
so the ramones and all these bands from
out of new york came
and i think this kind of like was you
know this you see grunge is sort of like
a replication of the what the punk was
doing then in that respect
in the 70s because um you know the
hockey stick guitars all the
new gear yeah that was the last time we
heard something
brand new like now when we went to the
90s and grunge we went back to les pauls
strats old marshalls organizers
but they used the big muff pedals which
were from the 70s which is that
wolfy fuzz tone like think of the solo
on wood by alison chains
that really will be like yeah so that's
all 70s gear so really grunge
was a reaction to okay these
these guys are dressed like women and
they have these these poofy hair
yeah they're not a mistake and they're
technically advanced and they get
everything right
now we're all going to wear flannel
whether we're male female we're going to
wear doc martens
so i call it um kind of snidely
mtv's introduction to their new hair
metal and their new hair
unbathes people in and then like you
know
bands like nirvana and hull would get on
mtv unplugged and they'd play out a tune
yeah in the middle and go we should have
rehearsed that and that was cool it was
supposed to be authentic then right
the idea was it was more genuine and
yeah but it but yeah right but it was
it's just a reaction to the 80s
now as you know as much as i was living
and i did love sound guard and
alice in chains i you know i thought
there were some great bands but all in
all i just saw it
for what it was we're not going to look
good you know it's like the 70s to the
80s it's like
no long soul is not and then yeah this
is actually where the british heavy
metal comes in where
it's kind of like okay we're gonna like
high and dry by def leppard
one of my favorite def leopard albums
great guitar sounds
and that's the old sound like yeah yeah
m45s
and the last pause and uh great
songwriting
um but the reactionary thing's very
important so i think grunge
was reactionary but it was kind of like
we're not going to use the new stuff
we're going to go back to what they were
using the 70s
uh but we do have new production things
like you know ways to record
when you cut when you call it
reactionary i think another way of
talking about it philosophically is what
we call dialectical right where there's
there's
something that's developing out of an
opposition to something else
but it's not just like flipping a switch
it's not like you just go right back to
the 70s because like you were saying
the the context is different so
yeah there's there's an opposition and
you generate something
new so emily says or this is
actually it's gilad watching with emily
um
to what extent was the new wave of
british heavy metal scene mythologized
by koran
karang magazine to what extent did it
coincide with british electronic noise
industrial or new wave scene
so with the second part it's not really
coinciding
uh as the new wave of british heavy
metal with with i would say any of those
scenes and and new wave is so
you know the like industrial is coming
later right new wave is around
and that's that's big in the early 80s
but they're doing very different things
than
the wave of british heavy metal people
are doing and i don't see any real
crossover between
between them in part they would be hard
to have crossover because there's not
there's not a lot of musical continuity
between the two you know
um new wave of british heavy metals
heavily guitar driven
virtuoso guitar performances riffs um
you know the bass the one continuity you
could say is maybe in base
right um and that's that's something
that's often overlooked
maybe we'll come back to that in a bit
but to go to the the question about
is this a real movement or not i think
that's that's what it what the question
is so
yes and no um so jeff barton is the
person who coins the term
and he uses it to to
try to bring a bunch of bands into one
one category and they are in
england right so he was he was told by
alan lewis and this is before karang
starts this is when he's still with
sounds which is a
british weekly and and i should mention
too the british weeklies
sounds was the only one that was really
interested in covering
metal stuff um in the 1970s metal stuff
was looked at as being kind of that's
for stupid people
you know people whose musical tastes
don't matter
and so so jeff barton's you know kind of
exploring new new territory
and so um he uses this term in a review
of of a gig on the metal crusade tour
that has
um angel witch iron maiden and samson at
the music machine
in london and he's talking about this as
being a new
movement now if you're looking at those
bands those are actually
i would say closer together in sound
than what the
ultimate new wave of british heavy metal
is going to encompass you know
you could say that there's extremes
right where like venom might be at one
extreme
and uh more melodic bands like um
praying mantis or tiger's pantang and
another iron maiden like solidly in the
middle
um def leopard maybe more on well i mean
they they're a whole different animal
uh saxon and there there's there's a
wider range that's being generated and
once
once it gets picked up as a
notion it takes on a life of its own
and kerang magazine is really central to
it
is is it a is it a mythos or is it
mythologized
by it it depends on what we mean by
mythologized
so that's actually a great way to to
think about it
is there a lot of like puffery and
[ __ ] involved in this definitely
articles and even more so if you like
look at how it was done here in america
with circus and hit parader picking up
on it oh yeah
i mean mom will you give me the new
circus
yeah we used to get it at the the
drugstore you know and i think i need to
yeah and and actually by the time that i
was doing that the
essentially the new wave of british
heavy metal it had run its course
because i was i was in high school uh by
then
but um there really was something going
on
it's just there isn't one single essence
i would say it's more i would say it is
more of a historical or sociological
phenomenon and it was this is where we
get into some something i did want to
discuss
oh wait before i'm sorry go ahead i
apologize i don't want to oh no
i wanted to interject on emily's um
the last part of her question to what
extent did it coincide with british
electronic noise industrial
i agree they don't really but here's the
thing that i always wonder
by the time depeche mode hit the 90s
and depeche mode started off as like a
synth pop band
yeah but then they became very dark very
heavy and then they led to bands like a
pop tigma berserk
um norwegian synth pop metal bands
yeah yeah you know i'd have to say
um as far as sonic the sonic influence
so like
if you listen to violator or um
you know uh any of the 90s
it's very dark it's it's it's got uh
dave gehan as this great front man who's
kind of like
yeah and um you could almost say is this
is this metal not in the sense of is it
the genre of metal but is it metal like
the ethos of metal
that's what i that's what i'm saying
okay yeah right so like
you know i went to the show and i got
the vibes because the the synth bass is
hitting me and
yeah yeah martin uh what's his martin um
gore playing guitar but he's not playing
heavy guitar he's playing these nice
parts
but um you know you have gehan being the
front man like you know
well like freddie mercury or you know
just a great front man
yelling getting the crowd going so yeah
i guess you nailed it it's
i think bands like that have that ethos
of
um in industrial it has maybe the impact
we might feel from heavy metal but it's
but we wouldn't call them heavy metal i
guess so i i think it's a
question that she asks yeah and i i
think those developments are coming
later than the new wave of british heavy
metal we can say so so what we can say
is it feeds into it
in in in some of the bands right um
and these guys like you know um i saw
dave gohan and
and martin gore interviewed and they did
say you know they were asked who do you
like they love black sabbath
they love interesting they grew up with
those records when they were young
yeah well they became you know when the
80s came and since came out and they
found their own path they did their own
thing which doesn't mean they didn't
have their
sabbath records um so by the 90s
time the 90s did they they became doom
and gloom and
um you know you you you got your moves
worth
for a show with them so i just think
that's kind of a cool thing because
um i was trying to plug that in myself
was
um well you know some of these bama pop
tigma berserk
you know the guitarist is playing heavy
and they're like they look like motley
crue
but it's kind of like a super heavy well
it's kind of like nine
there'd be no nine inch nails without
depeche mode there'd be no
so i think they're pioneers but they
ended up being very heavy
yeah not by our um
uh criteria i guess
well they're they're they're sort of
adjacent they're doing
they're almost pursuing something that's
not quite a parallel path but but it's a
at least a similar
path right a similar vector sonically
and emotionally possible yeah yeah
yeah yeah and and i mean that's another
thing too is is
is metal had not by the time that we're
talking about new wave of british heavy
metal we don't have this proliferation
of genres that people take for granted
today
right i mean we could identify scenes
and we could identify
sounds so like you know motorhead tank
raven similar sounds by comparison to
you know wrath child which is more glam
right or
some of the some of the other bands that
uh are around at the time like chrome
molly is more
more poppy than than those bands are but
they're we're not talking about like
actual different distinct genres
in in 1980 um whereas by 1986
87 we can talk about some really
distinct genres you know
thrash is on the scene drawing from new
new wave of british heavy metal
deliberately um
you know doing its its ethos and dress
uh by reaction against the glam stuff
you know so then and you could talk
about black metal proliferating after
that point too
um but going back to the to the um
mythology thing i think you can say
there was a mythologization
and there always is going to be in part
because there's
um you know the metal is larger than
life right
and there's going to be stories that are
told that aren't strictly true but make
a good story
but what they the there are some things
that we can point at you could almost
say in terms of communication or
material culture
so we talked about record labels earlier
and we talked about
um you know the rise of independent
labels
so like raven you know was on neat
records
and neat records could come along after
girl school got dropped by their record
label and say hey
we'll put you on our record label so
there was a lot of that
confluence of different labels there was
a lot of
pressing of eps and demos
and those would circulate around tape
tape copying
and playing was was a big thing in
britain at that time
the way it was for like me and scott and
probably i'm guessing for
for chris too um i'm not quite sure how
old chris is but he's probably of the
generation where you got a lot of your
exposure to bands by somebody saying man
you got to hear this let me make you a
tape right and so
that that was a significant part of how
bands got played
there was also like you know whole clubs
uh scene so you would go
to or around england which is you know a
small enough country
where you could be in this bar this bar
this bar and play
and then there were support tours for
bigger more established bands like the
oyster cult which was big in england at
the time
right some of these these new wave of
british heavy metal metal bands that's
how they got their exposure
uh touring with motorhead touring with
judas priest you know these
these well established bands but then
there was also a media thing too
so there were a few stations where they
could get
airplay and that was really important
because
you know these bands were not getting
radio play over here in the states which
was you know the prime market
to break into except for some really
specialized
places but they could there were some
some radio stations that would play them
in england
and or radio shows at least right and
and then they also got on this is
something scott and i were talking about
and uh nadia was was kind of helping
out with this they would get onto these
british music
shows that people would watch right
so so you know top of the pops um
or what was what were some of the other
ones i'm forgetting the names
will ferrell just did a movie of one of
them okay
um can somebody chime in because
nadia knows this um
and it was weird that will ferris did a
movie it's like top of the pops
and people try to get discovered and
some people get discovered
um but top of the pops is uh it would
happen yearly iron maiden was on it in
86
yeah um girl school got on there um
[Music]
judas priest was on it earlier um
unless i'm mistaking it for a different
show and so you know people would
people would get exposed to metal music
this way
and there probably was a lot of the
reaction of like young
people mostly guys who are like holy
crap what is this stuff the sort of
reaction like
i had for example when i made in the
trooper was uh put onto a van halen
tape that that a friend of mine made for
me that just happened to have like an
extra
you know seven minutes at the end so he
threw the trooper on and that that that
was transformative for me you know that
was my
i had my radio and it was actually
perfect because there was a thunderstorm
happening and there was this one hour of
metal this show would play
and this song started it was so intense
and i you know remember with our boom
box that we would record it
yeah and they didn't announce what it
was after
so i would over and i would show my
friends i go who is this and it was it
took me like six months to figure out
and then of course
i was hooked but anyways that's my
trooper's story yeah i'd forgotten about
that i would i would actually sit next
to my clock radio with a portable
cassette player and i would like
you know wait until the dj was just
about to stop and then click record
and that's how i got you know exposure
to songs that then i could listen to
uh afterwards sometimes they would
announce it sometimes they wouldn't
and uh but in any case yeah so there's
this whole scene
that is developing and it's not just a
scene of like clubs and people going to
clubs it's these distribution networks
it's these networks by which the stuff
can be can be heard
and you could say a lot of it was sort
of like right place right time
as we talked about a little bit earlier
some of the bands were not able to take
advantage of that
in the way that other bands were so for
example iron maiden
saxon def leppard they were all
positioned
by the time that this was happening to
like break out
raven always kind of struggled you know
there they had a lot of
they had a good fan base um they never
managed to make it to the level
that some of the others did tank also
struggled to a certain extent in ways
that
say motorhead didn't the band that's
probably closest to them in composition
and
sound and there were a lot of other
bands that just never
really were i mean they produced some
awesome stuff witchfinder general is a
prime example you know if you like a new
wave of british heavy metal that's
essentially doom metal
which fighter general is the band for
you they only
managed to put together a couple albums
some new wave of british heavy metal
bands
didn't get into it until mid uh
80s and i think by then it was a little
bit too late you know
to to get get the traction that they
they needed
now there's a the chris has an
interesting
point new wave of british heavy metals
alive and well today
check out the new album from witch hazel
this year yeah you know there's a lot of
new wave of british heavy metal bands
that have put out albums in let's say
the last decade or so
some of them are quite good scott was
talking about
um kickstarters raven is a prime example
of that
i mentioned they never really got the
the traction that they needed they
actually had to do a kickstarter for
extermination which came out in 2015.
they are actually i went on their
website they're in the process of
putting out a new album
and i'm sure it's going to be good saxon
consistently turns out
good albums um iron maiden of course um
you know who don't don't have you could
say the commercial
pressure if iron maiden wants to put out
an album they can if they don't want to
they don't have to
they're they're set for life whereas
bands like saxon have to stay on tour
bands like raven have to stay on tour
yeah there's quite a few of them girls
school put out a new album recently
rock got us did as well
and you know it's it's kind of nice to
listen to this stuff because it takes
advantage
of the um you know the technology that's
available sometimes the musicians are
actually quite quite better than they
were
back in the 80s that you know musical
because they've had
you know decades to practice um and
making some influence you know so yeah
we're trying to work stuff out
and then we have the luxury of just
taking what they did
and you know already sounding uh uh
you know already taking their struggles
and
uh spending some time learning it and
then we already sound
uh good to a degree thank thanks to them
and then you know we can build on that
and that's how the generations kind of
go up
so it's like you know the argument
ingredien is better than blackmore well
there would be no ingrain
there was no blackmoore yeah and like i
i disagree with that i think blackmore
is his own thing you can't there's only
one blackmore
you know the other thing is too i think
you're right as
as musicians are older it's they bring
a whole set of new experiences that they
didn't have when they're in their 20s
and 30s
to the resolving the problem that you
could say
is posed by each song and in some cases
there might be a bit of decline
particularly physical i mean you look at
like uh john michael thor
who used to be this you know he's a
canadian guy
you know front man of the band thor he'd
do all sorts of feats of strength now he
looks like
you know he looks like an old guy
[Laughter]
and i don't know that he has the pipes
anymore but when it comes to like
thinking think about somebody like um
again this is outside of the scope of
new wave of british heavy metal but
think about somebody like rudolph
schenckner you know
a really great composer somebody who's
content to stay on rhythm guitar
and let you know whoever it's going to
be you know his brother ulifan roth
uh matthias jobs handle the the solo
stuff but writing really really good
songs
you know age i think would um provided
you using it right
result in better songwriting you know
in many respects it's natural the
exception would be when you're just like
trying to take on the newest
stuff and we're gonna we're gonna sound
like these people you know um
we're gonna do what the the kids are
doing that probably doesn't work that
well what are you gonna say scott
you like you've clearly got some views
on that well
uh god there was like there was a few
points that and you kept
adding points um uh yeah i mean
if you think about it um you know
i think what happens with a lot of bands
is at this point they phone it in
so they could be writing great albums
but it's like wow why were the first
three albums so fantastic and these are
kind of lukewarm
um but then like you know blue oyster
cult just put a
brand new album out two weeks ago that i
think is in their top five
you could believe it they
you know they did not say yeah let's
just go in and
write some junk but it does happen you
know it's like there's
there's bands now that'll put out new
albums like um
uh well even if we take i don't know
we i don't know if we consider the metal
they're not metal but they used to be in
all the metal magazines night ranger
they put out like three albums and then
you go see them play they wouldn't play
one song from the new album
and i'd say like you know aren't you
guys playing the new songs
well it's because the albums aren't good
they phoned it and they put it out
just so the fans would say put something
out and apparently
nobody's requesting it so you know to go
but this is something we talked about
before so
but but to answer your question you
develop as an artist over the years and
so yeah you're correct it's
you might go in a different direction
but you're developing as an artist as a
musician
so it's not like you know great and then
here's me trying to do
an album from 30 years ago except i'm
not 18 anymore
you know what i mean i think that's part
of it is well it's like robert plant
robert plant's last album was phenomenal
but it had nothing to do with led
zeppelin
didn't sound it didn't have the zeppelin
vibe that kind of raises an interesting
point about like concerts
um when you have these bands that have
been around now for decades and decades
and so saxon would be a great example
raven would be another
one um the question is when you're
playing your older catalog
stuff from the 80s do you should you
play it like it would have sounded in
the 80s or should your sound be
let's call it updated right should you
should you um
do things a bit differently in terms of
the sonic profile of how you're you're
having all the instruments calibrated in
terms of the sound of the bass sound of
the guitar should you
should you drum the same way or should
you you know
use uh heavier forms of drumming that
are
became sort of standard from from about
the late 80s
onward um it's kind of an interesting
question you know so like when you see
judas priest
play some other songs in concert and
andy and i've seen judas priests four
times in the last decade
you know there are some songs that they
did from certain periods that
they're not going to play it exactly
like that you know
i mean my i have a feeling my own
opinion
and people might disagree if a band's
gonna
let's say a band let's say judas priest
puts out a brand new album today
yeah there's no coven and there's a tour
um what i would like to see is them put
out the best record they can
no matter if it's an acoustic album or
if it's something completely different
now what they should do is they should
place at least six songs from the five
six songs from the new album
but if they're gonna play the classic
stuff i think if they're gonna play it
they should play it like the classic
stuff this is something that um
in the 90s george lynch i felt like he
went wrong
so he he he he had a post lynch mob band
that was grunge
so he got the point where he was trying
to play like the kids
and then when he did the dawkins songs
he had a guy like
a cookie monster voice trying to do
unchained the night
and like you know with drama okay yeah
and so you know
all people like us were going you know
like
you know you want to do the new stuff
but then when you do the old stuff
you know it's cool like if you want to
do hits
do the hits um and you can change the
arrangements but
you know i always get bummed out when
the band's like we're going to do a half
hour acoustics out of
a medley of all our old hits and it's
like oh well don't do them then just do
the new album
yeah there's one from a thing from
alfonso he says i think in genres like r
b the evolution of recorded music
allowed vocalists to sing in
non-traditional ways
for example beyond classical training in
a more singy drony way
in contemporary metal though vocalists
have gone the other way as far as doing
extreme vocalizations in a controlled
way so what may sound like an
uncontrolled scream is actually done
with technique
they can actually last on a tour and be
able to speak in general so in a clue in
way the microphone
uh in addition to amplifying sound
allowed people to sing softer and sing
in new ways yeah i think that's that's
completely right i mean vocals now
are so much more of a technical
performance
than they were say in the 1980s when i
think most people were kind of winging
it
well yeah and you know it's the r b
thing that's a great
thing to bring up because you know you
have freaks of nature like sam cook
who's one of the greatest singers that
ever lived i think
um sarah vaughan or um you know and some
of these people
not them but um you know were extreme
drunks and heroin addicts
um sam cook wasn't uh but you know
they um they were singing from
they were pioneers but as it went on
then you get into like
the 80s r b the 90s or the 70s even
close temptations and everything and i
think
yeah um well again i have to go back to
we have the influence of
you know you know steve perry from
journey is a sam cook clone
you know he admits it and you know he
has all the same riffs but
you know he you could tell he just sang
to those sam cook records all the time
but then even post steve perry everybody
wanted to sing like that so they got
this vocal training that got the sport
controlled way i think that's
the the thing we're saying is that now
instead of like janice joplin
screaming into the mic and being drugged
out we have people that will do that
or what's the band um what's the
where are they from norway the the um
the
the this super heavy metal band it's got
that um
short blonde female singer and she sings
like
like like well i don't know
maybe maybe one of the the younger
people can feel that one
and they're a great band and she would
sing like lovely melodies and then all
of a sudden like this
cookie monster voice not warlock um
oh i'll remember but anyways how do
like we think how do we how does she do
that like if this was 1969
you know halfway through the tour or two
nights in
um yeah but i mean i i kind of think
that like
so like 70s 80s you you either had the
vocal chops or you didn't and
you probably didn't have very much idea
of what you were doing now there were
some singers who were classically
trained
you know um and there were some who had
amazing ranges jeff tate
you know and queensrake is a great
example rob halford obviously
you know um even you know i guess you
could even say dio
i mean dio was more of a powerful singer
than anything
else probably one of the most powerful
voices in metal
i don't know if i brought this up
a friend of mine years ago was
part of a festival my friend was my
friend plays for
a famous metal band um and
he got to meet dio of course he's my age
in this band
yeah uh he you know he's a guitarist but
he sings too and he said you know
it's a pleasure to meet you he said
ronnie was so
kind and sat down and took time but one
of the funny things was
so i sing a bit you know what kind of
warm-ups did you do
and dio says quite frankly son if you
have to warm up you don't got it
[Laughter]
yeah i mean sort of like star athletes
who who had
just raw talent who could get away with
it but then you look at you know what
what's
changed in sports in recent years and
people are like well you know
you might actually be a stronger
baseball player if you lift a few
weights every once in a while
and now we have people like you know
knocking home runs
out routinely so i think you could say
something like that happens
and you say something like that happens
with so let me ask you about guitar
right
we have this proliferation of the
ability to like
see what people are doing on youtube if
you want to see somebody doing
this particular solo or like you know
you can hear jk lee
talking about like bark at the moon and
how people often get the chord
progression wrong and here here's what's
actually happening
so having those things at your disposal
and not having to like figure it out for
yourself
it you know changes the learning curve
significantly right and and makes it
possible for people to
use technique rather than just relying
on
on just unpredictable talent talent can
always go away right
um so here's the thing about youtube
i've noticed a big problem with it is
that people
um we'll go to youtube
and well first of all before i go to
that
we all know about the instagram
guitarist right the 30 seconds of
i don't because i'm not on instagram so
tell me what what that is
it's people in their bedrooms that could
play these ridiculous tricks
and they're okay they put one up a day
and then they get a lot of followers
because it's like
like i know when it comes to my feed
because it's just this but
um or they'll play something they saw on
youtube you know
you know the click bait the 10 secrets
guitar
teachers don't want you to know and
here's the problem with it
all these videos are robbing people of
discovering their own voice
or being able to play in a band so it's
like you know
oh i just learned bark at the moon from
jakey lee i'm gonna put that on
instagram
oh i got 2 000 likes i'll do more of
that instead of
learning the um the actual
value of uh music
so it's kind of like handing someone a
paint by numbers book
one is green and don't get it out of the
line
oh you know oh you all like this picture
painting i did
rather than somebody getting a blank
canvas yeah
so it not that it's all bad but i'm just
but i think
um yeah although in this case it would
be you have to learn how to collaborate
with other people on that same canvas
right
so it's more it's more complex if if all
you do is learn
licks and and what's called licks and
tricks right
exactly various things and you don't
actually spend the hours and hours
playing with other people um
you're you're not going to develop in
the same way or you take these shredders
and then
you get them on one of these and i'll
say um play happy birthday
don't make a mistake and they should be
musical enough to have ears and put
outside put your finger on any note
play play happy birthday and they mess
it up i go okay so you're telling me
that you're going like this every day
you play a million notes but you can't
play happy birthday because you're not
so being a musician there's a difference
between being a guitarist or a drummer
or a singer
and a musician those are not the same
thing just because you play guitar
doesn't mean you're a musician musician
means you can speak to me the language
of music
to some degree right so so it's broader
in other words right and it can
interface with the others
so in a like serious sense it's like if
i get on a gig and there's a trio
um a bass player starts a groove and i
hear okay he's in the key of f
all right so boom boom and then we're
having a conversation speaking
um but if you get one of those people on
they'll do their three tricks
and then the show's over yeah and i
don't want to
you know that's always disrespect to
these people i don't mean to put them
down i'm just saying
it's launched a different way of playing
and let's not confuse
the youtube yeah flicks and trick for
developing a musician or somebody that
can function in a band or will have a
music career
well you know i think that's kind of
interesting and we
before we we end because we're getting a
little bit overtime we'll take
emily's other question but i'll say i
mentioned rudolf schenckner
and we can also talk about steve harris
and i think we can talk about d.o
and we can talk about lemmy
as people who did exactly what you're
talking about they were musicians they
dio was a singer but dio could play
every instrument i i've met people who
actually
worked with dio and they were surprised
to see him just like walk over and pick
up a guitar and say
this is what i want you to play well
theo could also walk up to vivian and
sing
yeah and expect vivian to be musical
enough to go
yeah you're saying this so so i think
with these like
let's call them super composers you know
um they're at the really high end of
what you're talking
about where they you know whatever's
going on in their their brain they can
they can visualize the whole gamut of
what's supposed to be happening steve
harris apparently is like that as well
you know
um he plays the bass but he he runs iron
maiden you know
um oh yeah he hears it all yeah well
it's very clear from bruce dickinson's
bio
autobiography that that is the case
um you know and and we could probably
point that out with others
let's take so emily has a good question
to go out on where should we situate
forgotten bands
um i don't actually know that the best
new wave of british heavy metal songs
are written by
uh hatch salem bashful alley [ __ ]
said mithra reincarnate i've heard
some of them you know mithra is good
i wouldn't say mithra is is uh
you know iron maiden good maybe saxon
good
um or you know they're all doing
different
things but where this is a great
question where should we situate these
forgotten bands
um i think that we can set say that
there was like a
almost like a top tier and and the top
tier is the ones that got the most
notoriety and they were able to
you know launch careers that would would
be well established forever and so that
includes iron maiden and you know
def leppard and sax and then there's
like a you know a second tier of bands
that
you know still have to struggle like
raven tank
you know some some of these these other
uh bands in there
that are still around maybe broke up
came back together diamond head i would
say
what's left of them is is in there and
then there's like the bands that
people knew about but but most people
don't know about
and so you know bring up mithra that's a
great example if you want to find their
stuff
i think the only place you can actually
find it is on youtube
because that's i think that's what i did
is i use the thing that allows you to
like download the
the video and turn it into an mp3 to
listen to them
otherwise i wouldn't i wouldn't have
ever heard them maybe you can hear some
other stuff on pandora i haven't been on
pandora for a long time
but it's not going to come up much so
where would we situate them
they're stuck in a kind of limbo you
know
and it's really unfortunate they will
probably
other than you know people who are
really into this this particular
movement of of music they're probably
not going to get widely heard
and i i don't know what we do to change
that and
you know maybe maybe scott you have an
idea or some of the other people here
have some ideas
about how we we um
how we get people to be more aware of
these bands i mean should we wear
t-shirts of them like
like charlie on um uh always sunny in
philadelphia doesn't look good
magnum kind of fits in there right um
there they'd be in that that
tier where things just never came
together so marx is an important step is
archiving
that's a good point you know a lot of
the if if this stuff is only available
on youtube
or out there in records that people have
in their basements
we're going to lose it because sooner or
later youtube will take that stuff down
and so you know we probably have to
figure out some way to preserve
this stuff and when when stuff like
tanks honor and blood is not available
in digital form
anywhere that i can see we've got some
real problems
you know that's a business thing i i
would it's my guess i mean i don't know
the
situation i mean maybe they said nobody
cares about us and we're not going to
put it out
you know but my guess but you know
to some degree um you know
uh being known or being on the top tier
is
not a meritocracy you know always i mean
yeah
i wouldn't say that iron maiden doesn't
deserve to be where they are
you know it's let's say iron maiden was
the third tier
i'd still be a huge fan right but i'd be
seeing
clubs at like um small clubs in boston
like the paradise
but um you know um you know there's a
a place for all of us and it's not
always fair it's like look at poor bob
geldof right the boomtown rats
and then he puts on you know he keeps
failing and he puts on live aid
by himself and you know that's a huge
success but he's always forgotten that
poor guy no matter what great music or
what grade record he puts out or what
great cause he does
you know he just gets a slap in the face
from the world and he put a book out in
the 80s call is that
it you know and the book was basically
like what do i have to do
you know um essentially i think
you know the fact that you bring up
these bands means they're worth a lot
more than the bands that stayed in the
clubs that were really good that
nobody they just died by 1987. and i saw
a lot of them in boston
in the late 80s early 90s that blew my
mind
but then you know it went to grunge and
they were too late and
yeah and then they just disbanded and
they got jobs and
um there's no reunions so i guess
i i i don't want to say it's like nobody
what's the right word um the preserving
thing is
is a good word i like that you know
you're pretty sure archiving
yeah archiving because um we're not
going to push them to the top because
you know for some odd reason it's like
you know we'll have our favorite band
and like nobody's into be like this
album's the best when i was in school
nobody cared and i wasn't gonna make
them care there's nothing i could do to
make them
i can make them listen to it i remember
playing my friend the the
new pete way album wasted and
he listened to two songs and shut my
stereo off he goes this is terrible
and left and i was like this is cool man
you know
but um what was i going to do like take
his head and throw it into the
tournament when you listen
to this album you know like you can't
make people
on different tiers but the archiving for
the people that do care
i think is important but you know i'd be
curious to be case by
case by like if their hands are tied
like if if you were to reach out to them
on twitter i'm sure
well a lot of these bands just have
they've
broken up and they're they're not they
don't have any presence anymore and
and uh i think you know the stuff that's
on youtube is primarily because
fans happen to have a mithra album or a
legend album or something like that
and then they they play it and sometimes
they record the entire album as a
youtube video sometimes they break it up
into
the tracks you know and that that's all
that's that's all that's available
you know my advice is the one thing
about
social media and i'm not great on
twitter i don't know a lot i am on
twitter but i don't do much
is it's it seems to be a great way to
connect with these people
so let's say one of these bands you're
really into and you know you can you can
say
um you can message them and you could
say hey you know
you're a great band where can i buy an
album
or you know how could i support yeah
yeah you know and they might be really
excited to hear from you and say hey you
know we don't have an online store but
if you paypal me
15 bucks i'll mail it to you and thank
you you know i mean yeah yeah
it's like they might have a stack of
these records in the basement
that's true yeah so that's what
that's a that's a good thing to end on
but there is also a good
quip from uh chris morrissey the medium
is the mediocrity
that i was laughing about a little bit
earlier
all right well thanks scott once again
for for joining us here i always
uh love being able to tap your expertise
uh especially on
you know me the you know the technology
and uh a lot of the the music history
that i don't myself
know and uh it's always good to get a
musician's perspective as well
especially one who's who
loves the genre so thanks everybody for
for joining us
and yeah we went a little bit over time
so you know
thanks for hanging out for the time
and
you